today on our show we don't go in West
young man that's right man we're gonna
dive deep into West world find out is it
real or is it Memorex
[Music]
welcome to Batman I'm Batman I'm Kevin
look Bernard okay man let's talk
Westworld going deep it's now over it
concluded last weekend with a bang
literally amazing and and I couldn't
guess that conclusion know if we have
sat me down in the chair naked like they
do a lot in that [ __ ] show oh my god
that was the one thing dude watch that
show over and over again I'm like even
if they were like keV dude we'll pay 25
million large seasons son they got a
[ __ ] sit there and all their glory
that is acting you gotta act and it's
not even just the [ __ ] naked as [ __ ]
but it's not even that you're naked it's
the position they're sitting in is that
least flattering for anybody like
Rodrigo Santoro who plays there like
this card was like one of the hottest
men on the planet he was he was Dirk
season 300 that [ __ ] doesn't
even look that good sitting down true
well he looks way better than I mean
better than I hunched over and his
postures horrible casting for the show
they put out a notice like you know
nudity fake oral sex and everyone's like
what's this show the act the Union I
think sag shut it down for a little bit
like there was there was all hubbub
because holy [ __ ] they're asking for
people to be like simulated sex scenes
nude furniture like all that stuff and
people like what are they doing new
furniture [ __ ] that warehouse full of
people yeah that's exactly what it was I
mean I know there's some digital
trickery involved to [ __ ] make a lot
of people but first two rows probably
naked people naked people just sitting
there dicks out and [ __ ] and then that
scene in the brothel when there's
literally it was like the Korova milk
bar but with real people just I'm
putting my foot up on this lady's back
because I'm an awful cowboy person yeah
it's it that's the thing about the show
it's like they build this amazing
[ __ ] world in insane detail like
where they have to craft the snakes and
the horses and not just the people and
stuff they fabricate this entire world
and all that anyone could think to do
with it is just [ __ ] yep and kill [ __ ]
and kill
and over again humans are the worst yeah
if there's one moral of this story if
the humans are the worst and that seemed
to be the upshot is that Robert Ford
played by Anthony Hopkins decide
wonderful work like in the beginning I
was just like boy he he's doesn't want
to be there and then you were like oh
it's a choice it's a performance yes and
he turns in like well I mean he's always
[ __ ] great but he turned in a really
[ __ ] fantastic performance and I can
you get the idea that he also agrees
that humans are the worst and so he
engineers well the whole time you never
quite trying to that's [ __ ] great
writing as well you never quite sure is
he even the [ __ ] bad guy yeah is he
crazy is is he a [ __ ] villain is he
and then is he detached does he not care
but then it's all revealed by the last
step which is stunning so he was
wonderful he's wonderful
Jeffrey Wright oh my god man is Bernard
Bennett Bennett standing new because oh
my god he's always wonderful but this
career-defining stuff for him for a lot
of people in the show maybe not Anthony
Hopkins he defined this perfectly you
sir he's got his own he's fine he's good
but but still he's turning in still
fresh original work and stuff but you
hang the guy like that you hang his
jersey like yes he's always gonna be
he's like Meryl Streep nobody's going
like wonderful Streep will be good this
time
you know Bethenny Hopkins he even he was
even a great Odin you know yeah even
when he was an odinsleep he was still
acting as a so he rode one tears right
that's classy acting right there just
writes amazing fantastic he's [ __ ]
deep other level stuff and you can't
really and spoilers if you're watching
this folks we are talking about the
[ __ ] spoiler I didn't see the big
twist coming eyes you know writer I felt
it in that episode like they started
dropping little hints and of course once
you get to the point where you reveal it
they say oh yeah the the the host can't
see anything they're not program I'll
see so like saying they were like yeah
what are the doors right there so I
don't see a door
and I'd really even considered that you
know like maybe some of the hosts are
maintaining those I mean I kind of
thought about it a little bit but then
cast it aside because like he and it's
the testament to the show is that it's
building these characters that are
artificial but have as much sort of
heart and soul as anybody else you see
on the show which is the text of the
show like it's subtext in its text and
I'm one of my favorite stories ever is a
person finding out that they're not real
and it just breaks your [ __ ] heart
like when Oh burn like once you realized
that he's a robot he's like no Charlie
my memories are real yeah it's a
backstory died my son and the whole idea
that and they get into it very much in
the last couple of episodes that trauma
is necessary for evolution yeah for
character building for character
building like we made everybody we built
you with with nice backstories and you
went off the reservation like you kept
wobbling and you couldn't keep your
loops and everything started to fall
apart it's when we gave you all sad
backstories then it helped everything
else stick it helped the rest of the
program and hold together and so the
idea that all of these people like the
trauma of the world knowing full well
that humans in a park like that only
want to commit trauma but like it is
just I love the way this show just
meshes itself together like it's it's
all predicated upon itself and all comes
from itself
bad robot producing so JJ's names on it
but it's it's Dolan Jonah no I think
that's short for Jonathan Nolan yeah so
someone that and he wrote co-wrote Dark
Knight didn't mm-hmm with Chris Nolan
yeah and I think he also had person yes
he had that show did he did he also
write inception with his brother that
I'm not sure what surprised me though
yeah especially watching Wes world that
wouldn't surprise me because it's
intricately plotted I know they got like
10 episodes or whatever to [ __ ] do it
but man they wove a web they really did
and they did it right in front of your
eyes I mean and most of it most of it I
was on board with
like I'm here from Ames story like the
Tandy Newton character [ __ ] go ahead
the brothel owner the former prostitute
the breakout [ __ ] star for me yeah
liked any Newton we're talking about it
before we rolled for my money gave the
best performance on TV this year Wow
it's it's unbelievably complex and she
does so much with so little they're just
moments where you just see like eyebrow
lifts and lip curls and dawning of
realization and all of the things are so
my Newton so just imperceptibly adjusted
and it all just sort of builds into this
amazing performance of a person who
realizes that she's a slave and realized
that that's like its it's the runaway
slave story you know it's very much the
like I'm learning enough about my
masters I'm picking enough fish and
getting enough that I've got a little
bit of information I'm gonna like read
the books I'm not supposed to read I'm
gonna get the information that's been
forbidden to me and I'm gonna get the
[ __ ] out of here and then that's that's
her story but let's and we'll go we'll
dive a little deeper into any new let's
jump to her conclusion of her story and
you know in the final episode you know
where you did you didn't you want her so
badly this time that [ __ ] train on
the train especially because when he was
going like no it says here you're gonna
you're gonna and they got to the Train
and she's like stop and she broke it and
she's like nobody controls me or
whatever so we never heard what the next
thing was whether she was supposed to
stay on the train or get off the train
and she you know that memory that just
[ __ ] like kills her and she knows
it's not real finally like broke her got
the train fantastic writing but that
performance will go back Tanny news
performance man and that character may
like going into it
probably in terms of expectation like
that's the storyline well I'll take a
leak or something like I'm not you know
you can walk away from the show sometime
by the end of maybe the first episode I
was like huh and then by I think second
episode she became the show for me and
that's saying a lot because there's a
lot of show to digest yeah and and it's
not like well this one's the weak link
nobody's [ __ ] slack
but man oh man that storyline was the
one that captured my imagination the
most whereas they all did that one
[ __ ] was time to be I can tell that
her performance really [ __ ] yeah sold
it from you right she just she really
[ __ ] communicates betrayal yeah I so
well and then quickly owning it as well
not betrayal like I'm broken but I'm
gonna use this hurt too real I'm gonna
I'm gonna use the trauma to move past it
so and then when you get to like when
she finds out the kids not real and
stuff and so nothing can stop her but
then ultimately like that's that's human
like getting off the train is the human
thing you know that's what I think like
she even though she knows that [ __ ]
kid is programming yep and not hers like
mother would never stay on the train and
yeah that's the moment where you know
she's been human for a while in her mind
but that's the moment where you're like
she is right and also we know that that
daughter that she had is real like that
that robot existed somewhere yeah as the
man in black talks about killing yeah
that was his like I went into that what
did it see how far would go and I found
this woman and her daughter and I
thought oh the mother [ __ ] and like for
a second she was alive and that's when I
knew that I was monster let's talk about
him so did you see those two storylines
being the same I [ __ ] with us yeah
like that that is my least favorite part
of it really that bums you out yeah I
was kind of like Oh cuz I was like [ __ ]
man they really like they they never you
know it was one of those let me think
back I'm like well they never said this
was now and when that picture was
introduced like I should have been like
wait a second that picture and I think
that was the first breadcrumb yeah like
it was it was the one thing in the show
that didn't seem to be playing fair you
know like everything else is on a rail
except for that you know everything else
is progressing forward like you get your
loops and all that stuff and I get that
but but that was the one way or a second
oh you know what if everything else is
gonna play by these rules why do you get
to play by those rules
just for that reveal
I like it's one of those you know all
you [ __ ] tricked me well done like
you know I fancy myself a writer and I
didn't even [ __ ] see that yeah all
their once they spoil it for you at the
end or once they reveal you do the die
backwards and you're like yes oh I see
oh I see oh I see yeah so I mean I
thought ed Harris Ed Harris had a really
wonderful scene for my money you know
he's always reliable ed Harris but there
was one scene not in episode 10 by
thinking 9 where who's the girl who was
in rocky who's like Oh a Tom Sowell
[ __ ] fantastic give her not that this
is the best reward in the world to give
any actor or actress but give her a
Marvel movie he has one she's in black
panther she's in Thor
she's Valkyrie really oh maybe she was
in Rocky or Creed yeah and he brought
Michael B Jordan it like that she's she
rockery give Valkyrie I think she's like
an insanely genuine actress like
especially and that's tough to say in
Westworld
what everybody is firing on also
Titans like it's one thing to get that
job on the dish they told her like
you're gonna be in West world I'm sure
she's like oh [ __ ] yes and then when you
look at the cast list you like to
display
yeah like any one of these people could
be number one in the Call Sheet of any
other show and they can act their asses
off but she [ __ ] stood shoulder to
shoulder with all of them even in scenes
with far gonna have any Hopkins she's
the real deal
she was wonderful I expected kind of for
her to be Tandy neumes daughter well
that could still do that they could
still do that I expected that reveal to
come at the end of it where that you
know because we don't know if hosts age
or donate we don't know if they built
the one that does maybe that's the
daughter she's looking for that well
what happened to her at the end party
scene did we find out
we don't see her die I mean the only
person meeting they didn't punish her on
camera you know she's gonna make it the
season - pretty sure
samurai world
[ __ ] yes well I mean is it was your
impression that that's the next Park or
that they've got a lot of parks I mean
if it's if it's like emotional art this
show will never have dude if it's like
the original the the original nature was
next there's a future world there was a
Roman world there was and there was West
world maybemaybe there's samurai world
is in place I mean we don't know where
this park is built we don't know how
many other parks it could it could be
like [ __ ] business world hey you know
Brussels across the street and hey
there's MGM's movie world and here's
debauchery world and here is samurai
world another Buck Rogers world I wanna
watch your show where does this train go
yeah and well that was my question I was
wondering if if she stayed on the train
if the train was gonna leave at all
mm-hmm because we never really saw
trample and did we um well when when
William first gets on the train we see
it pull in that's right well I went into
westward into West world but we don't
know where it's coming from
all right who else of course
Dolores hmm Evan Rachel Wood wonderful
and and man oh man like what a journey
she had to take and and she had to ring
a bunch of different bells including
playing you know kind of prairie girl
mm-hmm all the way up to I've now
attained the wisdom right and I am
become death destroyer of yeah it was
dope it was a really sweet watch and you
know in episode I think it was nine they
hipped us to the fact that she killed
Arnold and they didn't tell us how so
you had a week to be like oh my god she
just went human ape [ __ ] and [ __ ]
ripped him apart and then the
explanation was of course far more
satisfying Laura smash yeah that's what
I went for but instead it was really
[ __ ] beautiful on him saying like
these violent what does this violent
pursuit such a violent violent delights
oh my god [ __ ] heartbreaking [ __ ]
yeah I mean the one thing you know it
was really sweet though I thought did
you think you I thought Dolores is like
someone's coming for me and she was
talking about Billy Billy yes Williams
William which was Edie Harris right but
she was really talking about Teddy
mm-hmm so she double [ __ ] William like
where's William fell in love with the
robot and then when he saw her again she
didn't even recognize him because she'd
been wiped
there they are years later and [ __ ] like
that and she's going like someone will
come for me and he's like oh you idiot
it's me I've been here for the last 30
[ __ ] but she wasn't even talking
about him so it's like double [ __ ] you
but she was talking about [ __ ]
what's-his-face slops marsden james
marsden man [ __ ] yeah he was
wonderful I mean the one thing that I
want a little bit more out of was the
may reveal that she was the big bad
they're talking about like we we've got
a new antagonist we got a new storyline
it's all about Wyatt white is coming and
that she was Wyatt you never get like I
wanted more of the sense of the world
she Wyatt yes that's what they say was
it they melded her personality with the
Wyatt person oh that's right they'd said
that which leads to her killing
everybody at that party at that whatever
corporate function at the end but like I
just wanted more like what is hopkins
maker he says like in order for you to
he kind of like tells it he doesn't say
I want you to unless he programmed her
to do that why did she he wanted that
right yes like I think he wanted to die
in the same way that Arnold wanted to
die so that they would shut the park
down and give these posts a chance for
their own life like he wanted this the
the robot uprising
well like he programmed the robot
uprising that's what he was looking for
and so she was the instrument of his
like sealing the deal you know we are
never gonna be inviting people into this
park again to abuse you all we've given
you enough trauma for the last 30 years
that has been sort of building up like
[ __ ] barnacles on the side of a boat
and now you're all becoming a wave
and she was supposed to be the it's sort
of like executioner's sword that comes
in and seals that deal where she's like
this is our world yeah this is our world
belongs to us
so season two if you had to guess is
just war the robots
I mean fingers crossed man like whether
it's the tough season the top yeah who
wrote it was him
there's a lady - Lisa julissa joy his
wife she come from I think they worked
on Person of Interest together so
Jonathan or Jonah Nolan yeah is married
to Lisa and they ran the show together
was there they were the only two and now
there's a bunch of other writers on them
one of which Ed Brubaker Baga mix Marvel
Comics is and the Image Comics is a
creator of the Winter Soldier and you
think of Ed Brubaker that's how old
school I go I think Ed Brubaker is a DC
Comics really yeah wow man
really yeah mm [ __ ] I love one comic
guys [ __ ] get into the it's not like
you hey man it's better over there but
they pay better that's the big
difference
he's always great storyteller oh for
sure Wow I'm gonna go back and check out
yeah I think he's got a credit on one
episode I want to say it's like six or
seven okay good for him and he was in
the room for 30 weeks or whatever it was
they took and he's a class storyteller
but I was putting together like a
[ __ ] writers room for a smart show
yeah that's not [ __ ] a dumb guy to
have he's not been like I've done every
show there you know I'm fresh hungry
boys best ideas and he's also written
about 20,000 pages of comics like you
have to rely on a person to show up and
make things happen
doing a monthly comic for like six years
and being on time that's smart fiber get
a show [ __ ] yeah just get [ __ ]
writers from comic I mean comics dudes
and journalists that's right I'm just
saying [ __ ] you have to hit
deadlines that's true a deadline you say
for all you people out there he's like I
could be depended upon who else man we
talked we blew Tandy Newton Hopkins we
talked Jeffrey Wright a little bit and
he's fancy he's amazing
amazing and real and and Bernhard is a
character that like you know you always
kind of you felt for him especially with
the broken something like I remember him
doing the call with his wife which means
that call was [ __ ] engineered yes
well totally by the great Gina Torres
that's who that was
and it's so you know you get into you
get into his life a bit and you know you
start to like him as a person quite a
bit but I think I like him more as yeah
there's like as a host finding out that
he is what's his name Arthur North Way
is basically designed to be off to be
Arthur yeah which is lovely I mean I
there's a there's a story thing where by
treating your character so horribly to
begin with you automatically build
sympathy for them and I'm releasing to
Paul Verhoeven talk about that with
Robocop that the reason why Alex Murphy
has to die so [ __ ] horribly is
because you haven't gotten to know the
character all he's on the screen for 15
minutes but through that violence
through that torture through that trauma
you automatically feel for him because
in the depth of his trauma mom it's like
Harry Potter that kid under the stairs
you feel for him because he's been
abused he's been damaged he's been
totally and so the idea that this show
gets you on the side of the hosts like
you you start this show feeling for the
given it's awesome it's great we're
coming we're rich we're gonna have fun
in this part well by showing all of this
trauma by this repeated tremor by the
loops of trauma the show very nimbly
shifts us to their side so by the time
you get the robot revolution we're
rooting for the zombies and then I'm
dead and that's a [ __ ] trick that's a
writer right there
how eloquently put is that you're
absolutely right as a [ __ ] magic trick
yeah well I came you didn't even see it
happening until it happened no
phenomenal season one who else did we
not blow he's in the cast Marsden was
great yeah it's really strong like I'm
always surprised by him you know like I
didn't love his Cyclops because Cyclops
as a character is it's hard to be on his
side honestly I think what's tough to
pull off about the Cyclops performance
is most of the time your eyes
[ __ ] covered and acting it's all there
yeah it's all window to the soul so if
the dudes wearing a [ __ ] visor and
[ __ ] like that
but it's also like you want to gene
great to be with Wolverine because he's
[ __ ] Wolverine yeah like this guy
brings nothing to the table besides a
really nice pair of specs yeah he's he's
us Logan is the dick that the girl you
love goes out with yeah but you
understand the dick relationship a lot
easier than weird in that whole scenario
I always saw myself as Jean this is I
mean is there anybody else whose dick we
can suck on the show didn't get stuff
yet Jimmy Moses named Jimmy Harrison
Jimmy Simpson yeah young William great
job where's he from why do I recognize
you know what doesn't matter he was
phenomenal your heart broke form and
stuff but what a I didn't see the Ed
Harris coming one iota
so I'm wonder if that's a good thing or
a bad thing
Oh Jimmy Simpson's house of cards always
from that show from from Netflix from
the Netflix me neither my wife yeah I
mine doesn't and we saw that you guys
incited this if you haven't [ __ ] gone
west world you should because West world
[ __ ] rocks really really they did a
phenomenal job and storytelling like
this scares me every once a walk some
lycra [ __ ] I'm never gonna be this good
but I'm like you know what I'm never
gonna be good as good as a lot of things
like I feel the same way I watch Game of
Thrones I'm like never gonna be that
good so I think that's what I'm drawn to
the [ __ ] programming that I go like
man I can't do that that's a [ __ ]
magic trick and stuff but you watch
enough of that makes you stronger gives
you better ideas and stuff like that
makes you push harder go like that's
where the bar is [ __ ] I just got here
[ __ ] I better start the climb again yeah
and I it's a show that I think like I'm
gonna go back and we watch it maybe not
today or tomorrow but I think maybe over
the summer like let it sit for a while
and then we experience it and see if I
can pick up on all that [ __ ] that I
missed before
because you don't get a magic trick
without leave it hints you don't get a
magic trick without he says the drug
comes yeah you have to see enough behind
the curtain so that you were invested in
it and I just want to be able to see if
I can see all of those strings being
pulled I'll tell you this much right now
I'm gonna be bold and call it it's Nolan
kids going places I've never heard of
him before I'm not familiar with much of
his work oh but he's promising that's
cute I had no idea who's married to the
ladies you know because I watched the
after the show they shouldn't buckin
interviews and stuff they're like this
is what happened this week cuz I'll be
honest Marc not smart enough to
understand so I need to watch the after
show thing when the creators planet what
you just did
oh so then I could sit there and be like
oh so when I watch it I see both of them
interviewed but they never said oh by
the way we [ __ ] each other I guess why
but I mean I would if it was my wife I
feel like can you believe it can you
believe it this is who I get to sleep
with when we're done with his interview
she like would like to come back to our
house we call it Westworld
yeah all we do at our house about the
doing Westworld [ __ ] kill ya what do
you kill like I'm over and find out yes
when you call it there every house what
a great show man and [ __ ] JJ Abrams
plays a role somewhere
bad robot he's overseeing it all from
his ivory palace like is that what the
sports term is um yes and no like he's
had some misses on TV show called
Undercovers that was on NBC how long a
run one season yeah some of us don't
even get that and tell me was don't even
good I'll see what else revolution only
went two years what was that - yeah but
Indy like holy [ __ ] - go one with one of
my shows but every one every one of
these shows he sells is always like the
savior of the network of that year
that's not his fault it's not his
they're just like oh my god with him
comes a magic taalib rainbows and money
and that's not always the case that's
not always the case
I mean he's with this move you remember
super 8 super 8 did well but it didn't
like [ __ ] now destroy the world next
movie did did very funny
but yeah I don't know I think him is
just like like yeah watch Jack Black
Jack Black Jack like he's just excellent
at the game I mean I think yeah he's
absolutely excellent at it
I think the dealer busts some of those
times like he's not always pulling black
Giants
I'm good optic my whole career is
dealing [ __ ] bog that sir would you
like to stand on that nine yes I got
faith sometimes that works all right man
[ __ ] West world
yeah no watch it do it if you haven't
already [ __ ] loop it back there was a
minute where people are like man HBO's
[ __ ] after game now they've got West
world they got possibly samurai world
you can world this [ __ ] HBO could
literally become hpw just to [ __ ]
home box world show think about all new
[ __ ] casts and [ __ ] like that one of
my favorite things in this show and it's
it was tiny [ __ ] corner of the frame
where they're walking in that like the
dead corridor zone down there and
somebody's welcome out of hallway and I
could swear I need to go back and look
at it but I'm pretty sure that there was
just in the corner of the eye kind of
blurry in the background is a cowboy
when the cowboy hat and the black shirt
and the black pants that's supposed to
be your Brenner's really yeah like you
barely [ __ ] see it but in the we
don't even go to this floor anymore
these are the outmoded models we don't
talk about and there's a cowboy just
standing there
inactive against the wall man you got to
remember we grew up with a West world
yes but it wasn't this [ __ ] good no
Michael Crichton man he's the past right
yeah that dude must be [ __ ] smiling
wherever he is let's say heaven because
it's a positive show absolutely so he's
in heaven and he's just like I even rock
from here yeah they never do anything
anymore my [ __ ] name is Len
I'm on the Eightfold Path my friend and
it's all coming true all right we're
done we're doing this [ __ ] show
nobody's gonna give us a job I don't
give a [ __ ] I just like it it's good man
you know we want to tell the whole world
about my wife didn't want to watch it at
first the first time because she said it
was a member before they came out they
were like this shows kind of rapey and
right away my wife is like I'm on show
and I was like I don't think JJ would be
involved in a AP show and she was like
I'm home watching that so by the time I
got to episode 4 I was like look it's
not a rapist all like I've been seeing
any [ __ ] rape so I think you could
actually dig on and then by the time I
got to the end I'd be like you'd be an
idiot not to watch his show because this
is so in your [ __ ] wheelhouse and
yeah so hopefully she start in the gym
and my wife hates westerns so like that
first episode was a the only way that
she got into it was it's shot all around
California because there are still like
five or six standing Western towns in
like Santa Clarita and in the West
Valley there's Paramount ranch out by
like Thousand Oaks I think still got
those things and so we visited a couple
when you first moved here do them today
it was Drive and go see something we've
been to one of those ranches and we
would always tell me and we went we
visited one like six months ago
and everything was like shined up new
paint everything new windows I was
shooting there they were shooting there
like they do did it up for four
Westworld
here I was sitting there going they
probably went on location and built all
those towns now the room wasn't
immediate I work in production I know
it's vacant I'm like wow did you see
that space so digit oh no [ __ ] good
show all right and HBO's done it again
JJ's done it again
no lanolin's have done began apparently
what's her name Lisa joy Lisa joy who is
also in the Nolan family no and by
marriage has done it again man [ __ ]
hats off
Evan Rachel Wood did really good in that
shirt yeah really really good I mean
I've always kind of liked I was that 13
going way way back but like this is she
gets to do some pretty career-defining
[ __ ] I mean McGarity said that the lady
here the ladies on this show take off
with it no [ __ ] right honestly there's
no week like well nobody shines in there
but that's why I was [ __ ] like female
with robes and just keep swapping with
dissing your face
there it is folks [ __ ] now West will
give it a try
ah that's all we got I think so man I'm
Kevin Smith I'm mark when I was doing
the next time same bat time same bat
Channel SModcast icon or youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith
[Music]